peace be with you welcome to the D show
we got a lot of ground to cover today's
tattoos Donald Trump knock on wood I'm
not going to it and the five top
questions you'd want to ask or a former
Christian who's a mom now is getting
asked here on the D show don't go
anywhere we have an exciting show for
you peace be with you assalamu alaikum
imam Easter how are you well I alaikum
Salaam it's a limeade the peace and
blessings of God be upon you as well
Esau now that's named after someone
who's very familiar to the majority of
people who are maybe tuning in not yet
Muslims named after who Jesus Christ
peace be upon Jesus now what's they have
to do if I mean open up the Shona we got
a lot to cover how did you end up with
the name were you named before Jesus
orissa before you accepted Islam no my
given government name is actually matt
and not Matthew on the birth certificate
and when I became Muslim I started
learning Arabic and I realized that Matt
and Arabic actually means he died so I
was like his name is a little bit maybe
difficult to go over if I ever travel to
the arabic-speaking world so I decided
to go with the name asa which means
Jesus which is a good thing to bring it
up when i'm introducing aslam to people
who don't know about it in this
particular part of the world that's very
very interesting cuz some people right
away we're clearing up a misconception
because some people think that Muslims
of the Antichrist actually we love Jesus
so much and you're a living example that
you named yourself after his name right
actually in the Bible in the book of 1st
John the writer of John says that anyone
who declares that Jesus is the Christ
who's come in the flesh is a spirit of
god and anyone who says otherwise is a
spirit of Antichrist so for me as a
Muslim now having come out of
Christianity I still affirm that very
fact that Jesus is the Christ he is the
Messiah now we opened we got a lot to
cover will get into the Donald Trump in
a minute and we'll get into the tattoos
because you're actually my Imam now you
went not just from being a regular
Muslim sort to say but you stepped it up
and you really took on with the studies
and you became any mom tell us about
this
well I mean I maybe not the Imam in the
traditional sense I started off as a
what you would call Muslim coordinator
which is actually kind of a good
definition for Imam and English at a
private university in north carolina and
it was after i had completed some arabic
studies and essentially for an entire
year their eyelid salotto jomana the
muslim friday prayer service and
counseled the muslim community there and
took care of the holidays and elected
stuff and then eventually around the
time i got married that job ended and i
had no work and i applied at this
organization called al for Khan
Foundation and they were basically
looking for a traveling a mom which
means that you have all the
responsibilities of any mom you have to
lead prayer you have to give friday
sermons you have to give lectures and
all that stuff but you never have to
stay in one community very long just a
weekend so so tell us it's very
interesting you know people would say ok
this guy is born in america right and
you were former Christian yep so I'm
sure you get a lot of questions asked oh
yeah ask you so we want to know the five
top five top questions that someone
might ask you as to you know as when
they hear that you're actually not
Muslim can you share with one of those
with with us please um yeah I mean I get
all kinds of questions everything from
you know I guess theological questions
to personal questions I guess I can just
start with a personal question a lot of
people ask me like what made you want to
be a Muslim and I you know it was really
a three-tiered process the first step
was I actually met a Muslim which
interestingly enough I kind of grew up
in a white bread world and I didn't
encounter a lot of people who weren't i
guess like me and all of a sudden one of
my older brothers came home one day and
told us he was Muslim this was kind of
strange because he was a former
missionary you know studying to be a
pastor and so he was kind of the first
Muslim I ever met that I guess revealed
to me their religion I had probably met
Muslims before that and so I watched him
and watched his practice of the religion
and learned about it first then he
challenged me to read the Quran and that
was the next step when I opened the
Quran I had a very unique experience
with that book even in the English
language that I had never had
any previous book and then finally it
was through the experience i was having
reading the quran that made me
interested in who wrote it because back
then i'm thinking someone wrote it so i
went and learned about the Prophet
Muhammad may God's peace and blessings
be upon him and that was it for me once
you learn about him and you learn who he
was and what he was able to achieve what
the little means he had and the fact
that you know fourteen hundred some-odd
years later there's still almost two
billion Muslims on earth following you
know the religion that he brought that's
a pretty powerful fact for me what's
another common question maybe not
personally to you but some in the Dawa
possibly someone wants to learn to have
misconceptions about Islam you traveling
a lot what's another common question you
get asked um I get questions about
covered one now yeah especially so
specifically from Muslims I get
questions about when it comes to doua
like how can I convince so-and-so to be
a Muslim and I always try to you know
sit them down and explain to them what
the goal of Dawa or inviting to Islam
really is it's not necessarily that we
need to have in our hearts that we want
to change so and so's religion or any of
that kind of other stuff but more or
less than we want to deliver the message
of Islam to them and then you know God
Almighty changes people's hearts so I
explained to them that you know the
first thing the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him ever did in
his Dawa was he established himself in
society as an honest upright person
before he ever called anybody to any
religion and so the first thing that you
want to do anybody wants to do when
they're telling someone about their way
of life is they want to have the good
character and honest and upright
reputation that the Prophet Muhammad and
all the previous messengers have now
what happens if you're in a situation
that you are you're building up to that
to becoming a better human being you
gotta Dawa opportunity but someone says
you know what I'm not there yet I don't
have the best of character should that
be an excuse not to go ahead and pass
along a brochure pass along some good
information no because the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he made it very easy for us he said in a
sound hadith he said belly go and evil
oh iya which means to convey from him if
only a single statement like one verse
of the Quran or one of his prophetic
hadith and so you know
we can all do a little something but it
is important of course to understand
that when you're involved in Dawa to
understand that first steps would be to
have that good character but no one
should say that just because I'm not a
perfect Muslim I can't talk to someone
or give someone information about it do
your family members have they been
receptive do they ever ask you like why
do you have a beard now no because I had
a beard before I before actually the one
thing I that I learned in Islam was to
cut the mustache I used to always like
let my mustache grow and I would really
bothered me when I would eat and so when
I became Muslim it's you know part of
our our following of the Prophet
Muhammad to trim your mustache so now I
keep that consistent you know styles
change trends change and we see now
yesterday what was in you know it's
faded out but you can see now people are
the the we don't do it because of that
but the beard is have you notice is
getting hip now well that's a good thing
i think you know i mean i believe that a
man should have a beard I mean God
Almighty gave us facial hair for a
reason uh-huh that's true yeah yeah but
you're right the Styles do come and go
so yeah and we see all the prophets
Jesus had a beer and Moses had a beer
and all of them had beers is saying it's
interesting you know being in martial
arts or someone who was in the sport
you'll see or a fan of some of the other
martial arts someone's preparing for a
fight they want to bring this this
masculine side out of them next do you
know he's got like big beard he's
preparing to get mentally ready for his
match right right exactly so we're gonna
we're going to before we go to break you
were also involved into entertainment
industry was that also as a Christian
before you were involved what are the
things were you doing before Islam well
I mean you know I I definitely was born
and raised as a Christian and spent time
you know going to church and going to
Christian camp and all that good stuff
but around the age of 13 is when I got
kind of interested in entertainment
world and I started playing the bass
guitar and that opened up all kinds of
doors for me and I spent a long time an
entire decade and entertainment business
both performing being a stagehand
recording records you know I even got to
you know be us basically a sound guy
producer live concert venues my work
with famous people used to work with
jay-z's engineer
here we want to Grammy for one of his
records I did a lot of interesting stuff
we're going to take a break we got a lot
to talk about we want to be efficient
with the time so we're trying to get
some of these questions and also along
with your story then I mentioned Donald
Trump you were like well how is he
getting in a mix of this well we got
that to talk about as a question people
are asking about tattoos we got an imam
here so we have a lot to talk about
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
please subscribe to the dvo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below please also help
support the V show by making a donation
in the link below back here on the Dean
show so now you're in the the whole
world of entertainment works opens up
you Matt jay-z how do you get in what
would you mention about Jay he said Jay
Z yes actually I used to work with with
one of his engineers that engineered his
album well I don't necessarily need to
mention the name of it but it was one of
his records and he we used to work
together whenever we would go out into
the live sound world so I got to work
with a few famous people you could say
now did you end up somehow because we
see another growing trend and we get a
lot of questions asked here to the
addition we usually you know try to
direct them to people of knowledge or
whatnot but the thing is now we know in
Islam that there is especially in this
world opens up an entertaining people
are looking for an identity so they put
a tattoo here put a tattoo there put a
tattoo it everywhere right but you ended
up you at the end you didn't get no
tattoos at the end no I don't think I
was ever interested in having some sort
of permanent picture on my body yeah
that just never appealed to me yeah so
what would you now is a you know a
person that you go to a community and
people they relate with you more because
you've grown here you understand the
culture at times and someone's just like
maybe they're new to Islam and they
start bringing up you know what I tell
usually people is yet you know Islam is
so flexible that yeah you want to tattoo
you have actually the temporary tattoos
that you could do and that's right the
henna right a clear okay so what would
you tell someone now they're thinking of
getting a tattooed and that's may be
right there that borderline accepted
klima say how would you answer this well
yeah I mean actually what you brought up
is an excellent point and one of you
know the scholars I heard him answer
this question the same way he said that
you know we have these temporary tattoos
in Islam you can change the picture
every month and then eventually it's
going to fade away and so you never have
to make that long-term commitment and it
can be you know whatever you want and
you know my wife seems to really like
them also so yes temporary but now many
people they end up why do you think
people go gravitate towards getting
these tattoos I don't know I mean I i
I've had many friends throughout my life
who have them and they get all kinds of
strange things tattooed on them from
demons and Dragons and people's names
and you know and I've also met people
who got them a long time ago and they're
kind of faded and runny and so I really
i just i don't know if it's just some
way like you said of having a personal
identification marker on you that
distinguishes you from other people i
think actually now when did you feel
once you found islam the gift of islam
that you actually now you discovered a
whole new world need discover yourself
and many people if they would look into
islam that these doors of trying to open
every door but usually it's the wrong
door you know you get into tattoos drugs
all sorts of crazy things searching for
something and usually it's not there but
with shlom did you find what you were
missing what you were looking for
actually if I had to describe my life
before being Muslim it was very much a
journey from one you know one physical
pleasure to the next just trying to like
pass the time feeling good you know and
the entertainment industry is great for
that because music is you know a type of
drug really and if you know people would
really study at they would understand
that you know it affects the same parts
of your brain that actual drugs do and
you know so when I became Muslim it was
the first time in my life and I always
describe it like this that the someone
turned on the lights in a dark room and
that room had been dark for 25 years of
my life and when the lights came on i
didn't know what i was looking at yet
but i could see and i didn't want the
light to go off and you know almost
seven years later today I understand
what I'm looking at and I certainly
don't want the light to go off and i
also like to see the
light turn known for other people
because there's a lot of people who are
like me who had spent those many years
of their life and essentially darkness
that's the best way I can describe it
you know I think about this sometimes
when I'm searching for something in the
dark and you can't find it or and it's
something it's maybe it's it's it's
actually a handspan away somewhere but
you cannot find it on the floor wherever
it is and I usually think about that say
look you know what about going through
life in that darkness yeah I mean it's a
for me like i said i mean i was always
grasping at something to like just you
know make me feel good you know with my
life but really there was this inner
yearning of understanding like what on
earth is the purpose of life it can't
just be you know to you know make good
music or be a good citizen or you know
be a good neighbor a good husband have
three kids in the house and a dog and
you know those things that just can't be
all there is to life and those these
actually would be people end up taking
at the means as the purpose because
having a family be one of the means to
the ultimate goal of the pleasure of the
Creator that happens on earth would you
say all these things are not excluded in
Islam some of the things but people end
up taking these things the means as the
ultimate goal yeah exactly and Islam you
know a lot of people don't understand
this but you know it's an Arabic word
and so let's demystify it today for your
audience saying that it means surrender
and submission to the will of the
creator and it's through surrendering
and submitting to the will of the
creator that one finds peace and I've
heard you say that many times and that's
a great way to describe it because
essentially what you find in Islam is
that God's will is in company of
everything but the human he has the
problem to deal with it either
submitting to that will or rebelling
against it and even in other world
religions like the Dow they talk about
the Dow running through everything and
the more you surrender to the dowel the
more easy and peaceful your life becomes
and this is kind of similar not exactly
the same to what we have in as long
zipper surrendering to the will of Allah
God and so through doing that you know
you actually become more in peace with
the world around you yeah and and
there's a very beautiful hadith from the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him where
he was sitting with his companions one
day and a funeral procession passed by
and he said out loud relieved or
even and the people asked him they said
I most a messenger of god what is
relieved and relieving what do you mean
he said when a righteous servant of God
is taken from this world they are
relieved of its hardships and trials and
they enter into the mercy of God but
when a disobedient servant of God dies
they are relieving the people the land
the animals and the trees of their
wicked behavior so from that I've really
come to understand that to be a Muslim
to be someone who says they've
surrendered and submitted to the will of
God is to be in harmony with everything
around you and to be a benefit to
everything around you that's deep that
is deep before we go to break give us
one more common question you get asked
maybe from your family when you first
accepted Islam give us something before
we did we've done two already that the
one about the beard encounter I asked
that so give us one more okay so so on
that same point when I first became
Muslim a lot of times you encounter a
lot of different cultures and so at
first you don't really know what the
difference between Islam and culture is
so I used to put on all of these like
the way they call them to Thome and
Goofy's and all kinds of different
things and people would always asking
about them they're like oh what's with
the hat what's with the clothes one time
I went with an imam to a farm for the
Eid al-adha festival where we a
sacrifice an animal for the sake of God
and I remember the preacher that ran the
farm he said you know why is your later
in a dress so you get a lot of questions
about clothes and why people have this
and that own so you have to explain to
them a difference between culture and
Islam beautiful we're going to take a
break and then who does Donald Trump
when he comes from a doctor and he's
feeling great and has great health who's
he thinking and who should we be
thinking and we're going to be
discussing the other then we got two
more questions here left on the D show
with former Christian entertainer and
more here in a dish oh don't go anywhere
we write back please subscribe to the
dvo follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with imam ISA named
after one of the mightiest messages that
was sent by God calling people to
worship God did he ever say he was God
not that I'm aware of I don't think in
any version of any kind of Bible and we
know there's many different versions of
the Bible have you I mean you're
proficient with the Bible correct um
yeah I mean I grew up as a Christian and
I actually still read the Bible a
regular basis I'm kind of into
comparative religion so kind of like
soccer naik yeah a little bit I'm a huge
fan of his teacher I am indeed and may
God have mercy on his soul yeah so now
you you you don't have you found an
explicit statement where Jesus ever said
i am the literal Son of God came to die
for your sins I'm God one in the three
ana trinity have you ever seen this no
actually the most explicit statement
I've ever seen in the Bible from Jesus
Christ peace be upon him about
particularly salvation like what it
means to be like in good shape on the
day of judgment is I believe in John 17
3 where he says this is salvation that
they may know you the only true God and
Jesus whom you have sinned that's deep
yeah that reminds me of the the Shahada
like there's nothing worthy of worship
except the crater that happens in the
earth during that messenger who was sent
at that time was Jesus now it's Muhammad
peace be upon and interestingly enough
on that point the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him said that anyone who says
the Shahada right there is nothing where
they worship except God and that
muhammad is God's servant and messenger
and then adds to that that Jesus is
God's servant and messenger that he is
the spirit of god that he is the word of
God bestowed upon the womb of Mary that
paradise is real and that the Hellfire
is real anyone who says this according
to the Prophet Muhammad will enter
paradise there any gate they wish and
the sub narrator the hadith says even
though their deeds may be few that's
deep yep okay we're going to take you to
a clip everyone can see of Donald Trump
and we let them watch this I actually
saw a doctor I had a physical the other
day and they said you are really good
well yeah you can all hear it would you
like to hear it i would i would do that
anytime yeah very good knock on wood
knock on wood knock on wood okay now you
saw Donald Trump he's running for
president right and he was asked
commenting on his health and now what
would you
ooh if someone came to you now and maybe
you saw this person second time third
time just accepted Islam and you ask
them a Steve so how's everything going
he said man thank God is going good or
heating he said you know he said yeah
thank God is going good he didn't knock
we pick up some habits from the past how
would you address this um well I mean
depending on how long the person had
been Muslim I may let it slide at first
or something like that but I guess maybe
eventually after some time and past I
would just mention to them that you know
whether they knocked on that would or
not it really wasn't going to make a
difference because the woods not
controlling the universe exactly you
know but these are just these are
cultural superstitions that Americans
have just like any other culture you
know we do all kinds of things like that
and not going what is a very famous one
doesn't surprise me that a presidential
candidate would do something or say
something like that kind of tells us a
lot actually a little bit but a lot he
didn't actually even say thank God and
knocked he just think he knocked onto
wood when I looked into this a long time
ago I saw that there was a I believe was
a Scandinavian tree God that people used
to knock to wake up to pray to did you
hear anything like this before no I'm
not aware of the origins of that
particular superstition but I've heard
and seen many guests on your show talk
about some of the other ones yeah so so
so again I'm sorry so how would you so
why is it why is this so I mean because
someone asks us how you doing it and and
we give all the reverence and thanks to
the same one that Jesus did to God
Almighty you know why is it so important
you know we can see people like they end
up you know doing many of these
superstitions and they don't even think
about it why is it why is this something
that you know is so prevalent nowadays
well I mean you know when you don't
understand that that Allah God Almighty
is controlling everything and running
everything that his will is prevalent in
all things at all times you can easily
fall prey to these kind of superstitions
because you know you you're ingrained as
a young person to think that if I don't
do this certain act or I don't knock on
wood or whatever it is that something
really is going to happen
and and you've convinced yourself of it
and even if most people are question
about they'll say they don't really
believe in it but well then why do you
do it in the first place and it should
be something that we just recognize
about our own selves and say to
ourselves is this even something
necessary and it's just the same thing
that the Quran presents you know as an
argument to the the first people that
the Prophet Muhammad came to the tribe
of Clarice you know they only do what
their fathers taught them it says that
so many times in the quran and the quran
asks the rhetorical question even if
your father's didn't have any knowledge
of god you know it asks them questions
to make them think and reflect on what
they're actually doing in life and
you'll see someone will claim i I don't
believe like we don't that someone is
purely an atheist right because everyone
is born with that name nature to believe
in the crater they cover it up but even
someone who will claim to be an agnostic
atheist for instance they'll have a
bunch of these if you look at their life
they'll have a bunch of these these
rituals that they do these superstitions
a good luck you know t-shirt when he
goes out good luck soup sued throw some
what's that over his back salt and he
got he has to do that otherwise it's his
bad luck well you bring don't get no
good luck yeah you bring up a good point
actually one of the most powerful verses
in the entire Quran for me I don't have
the reference for you right now but it
had to do with God talking about how
when people are at sea on a boat and a
storm comes all of a sudden like when
things get really bad and they're
thinking that their life is about to end
they will call on the only true God
one either but she of emotion collude
Anita Elohim of machine and a Houdini
everybody will and I knew that I knew
that from living life that that
statement was true that when it really
came down to it even people who claim to
have no faith whatsoever when push comes
to sup to push comes to shove and their
life is in threat then everyone will all
of a sudden be conscious of that one
creator that made everything we got two
more we've done three give us two more
one more two more common questions you
get asked I get a lot of questions about
how my family reacted to me being Muslim
and actually the good news for me was
that my my brother had already become
Muslims so they already kind of knew
what Islam was but for him he
encountered a lot of initial abrasive
attitudes for my family because you know
unfortunately they were like the rest of
us they didn't know anything about Islam
and unfortunately a lot of people miss
introduced to Islam by the television
set or the radio or the magazines and so
a lot of his initial explaining Islamic
people was just kind of demystifying
common misconceptions but when I came
along I remember the day I came to tell
my mother that I was Muslim and I put on
a kufi and met her for lunch and I said
you know Mom Muslim and she said well
whatever makes you happy that wasn't
exactly the same reactions you gave it
to my brother but so that was for we got
one last one final one of the we call it
the top five but that you remember of
people asking you common questions not
at your Muslim well I'm going to give
the last one to you you get to ask me a
final question then there's a lot of
Islamophobia out there and people are
scared they see you maybe you fly and
you get hassled at the airport a lot of
people do because they're trying to
practice this this pure way of life pure
monotheism not trying to harm anybody
being a benefit to society and I'm sure
you've been asked this have you people
thinking now that you've accepted the
other and they equate you in Islamic
terrorism what would you say well I mean
I would just tell them that you know
Islam is a gigantic tree right i mean
there's almost some say close to two
billion people on earth and out of that
tree we have bad apples we
of our mentally ill we have our
misguided and ultimately Muslims are not
angels we weren't created to be perfect
and so we do sin and we do have people
who do a lot of bad things and we are a
huge tree so sometimes it appears that
many of us are doing bad things but the
reality of it is I would highly
recommend anyone who has these kind of
suspicions of Muslims to actually get to
know one and that's why I teach the
masajid the the Muslim houses of worship
all over this country whenever I'm able
to do something like meet your Muslim
neighbor which is to invite your
neighborhood to come and meet you and
sit down and eat a meal with you and
you'll find that those misconceptions
will dissipate very quickly we gotta go
but if someone out there not yet Muslims
however an organization university they
liked what you had to say and they want
to learn more about Islam and Muslims
how would I get a hold of you you can
get a hold of me personally through the
Alpha confound ation I'm part of the
Alpha confound ation division called for
calm project which distributes the Quran
in English and Spanish for free all over
the country you can go to fork on
project org and then also there you can
click on the Dow a training at fork on
project org and there you will find meet
your Muslim neighbor and and shot a lot
you'll also find my contact information
there thank you so much may god almighty
love rewards you for your wonderful work
and all of us I mean thank you so much
no problem and thank you for tuning this
subscribe if you have not already we had
a lot of things that we covered tattoo
you're anxious you want one hey look
look into what is there to this life is
it just about getting tattoos partying
rock hard and then what you just fall
asleep with a hangover and you're right
back at it throughout the whole week to
the next weekend no and then for those
now you learned that there is something
in Islam temporary tattoos right because
you go and rent a car you don't just go
and put the rims on it and give it a new
paint job no no this body is this a gift
from God and we can't just do whatever
we want we're gonna be responsible and
who do we thank for this look we don't
take think a tree or knock on a piece of
wood I'm not going to work we thank the
one who created this whole universe and
everything and it the one Jesus thank
the one he called to God Almighty that's
an Aramaic Aloha
then we saw another individual who has
also made this conscious decision that
yes indeed this way of life from the
craters the submission to the will of
God Almighty alone is the truth and he's
accepted it and you see the peace now
that he's living the purpose because he
found it and you can also find this all
you gotta do is ask ask the one who
created you in a world of confusion what
will set you free the true but you have
to ask the owner of truth the one who
created you and if you have any other
questions call us at 1 866 to islam meet
your Muslim neighbor meet your Muslim
neighbor he gave you some information
how you can contact the organization you
can also give you a free car and that's
what they're all about and we'll see you
next time subscribe if you haven't until
then peace be with you